[Music]
we all have our favorite childhood toys
Barbie dolls teddy bears security
blankets and so on but what if we told
you those toys could cost millions of
dollars wait until the ends of this
video to see the most expensive but also
the most amazing toy we have ever seen
don't forget to hit that notification
valve to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
the 10 most expensive toys in the world
diamonds Barbie the very first toy on
our list is actually a Barbie doll yep
but this isn't a doll you'd find in the
tall's collection this doll was designed
by an Australian joy designer who wanted
to create the most expensive Barbie ever
so naturally she put diamonds on her it
might look like a totally normal Barbie
just about anyone can play with but this
fashionista comes with a choker necklace
and has a one carat square cut pink
diamond pretty impressive right but you
absolutely wouldn't be able to get this
Barbie in your childhood well at least
not unless your parents are billionaires
the dolls necklace costs an impressive
$300,000 although it costs so much money
the doll was actually used for good it
was auctioned off in 2010 for three
hundred and two thousand five hundred
dollars that all proceeds were donated
for breast cancer research this has also
been by far the most expensive Barbie
ever a previously pricy Barbie record
was held by a doll that costs seventeen
thousand ninety one dollars it was sold
in 2006 although still impressive we
can't believe someone even dared to make
a Barbie doll even more expensive than
that we would never even want to play
with it yet alone give it to a child it
just looks too gorgeous to be true gold
rocky Norris
if you thought owning a diamond Barbie
was impressive wait until you see this
one rocking horses usually come with all
sorts of detail that make the rocking
way more fun the kids these days have
outgrown rocking horses which have been
replaced by well rocking technology most
of the 90s kids will remember either
owning a rocking horse or seen it at
their grandparents house but when they
owned it might not have been expensive
but this one is this is a rocking horse
designed by a Japanese jeweler who
decided to create a 24 karat
old horse toy back in 2016 it was
originally meant to be a tribute to the
birth of a Japanese Prince yep that's
pretty impressive right wait it gets
even better one lucky kid in this world
actually owns this gold rocking horse
and her name is Blue Ivy that's right
they and jay-z actually bought this
horse and it costs them an impressive
six hundred thousand dollars ah the
lifestyle of the rich and famous
according to the rumors back in 2012
Blue Ivy got gifts worth 1.5 million
dollars question is how did the Japanese
Prince feel about the fact that his gift
was bought out by the one and only
Beyonce seriously we need to know the
masterpiece Rubik's Cube most kids have
a love-hate relationship with the
Rubik's Cube were you ever able to
figure out the algorithm and solve it
can't relate really we all know Rubik's
cubes come extremely cheap these days
but what's better than a cheap Rubik's
Cube an expensive one this thing is
called the masterpiece Rubik's Cube and
it costs an impressive 1.5 million
dollars it was created to commemorate
the 15th anniversary of Rubik's Cube
back in 1996 but what makes this so
special is the fact that it has actual
rubies as well as other precious gems
185 carats of precious gems to be exact
we're not even sure we dare to even
touch this one yet alone figure out the
combinations to get single colors on one
side we'd be too busy processing the
fact that we're holding a 1.5 million
dollar toy in our hands of course
expensive toys like this one aren't
meant to be played with but if you're a
die-hard Rubik's Cube fan this is a
perfect gift if your bank account allows
it of course
not impressed by the cube stick around
because we're only amping up the toy
price yep there are seven two is out
there that are worth more than 1.5
million dollars golden monopoly we're
not lying there's a golden monopoly out
there while we don't think playing with
the gold monopoly would make the game
any less frustrating it would probably
prevent your family members to flipping
the table when they get angry seriously
it's a monopoly made of gold this one
was designed by a San Francisco jewelry
designer back in 1988 and it took him a
whole year to make this game yep a whole
year
we can't even imagine
what that must have looked like if you
had to choose between playing Monopoly
for a year or making it which one would
it be we can't decide which one seems
more frustrating so how much does this
gold board game cost well the set of
dice is about $10,000 because the dots
are made of 42 full-cut diamonds
the properties are made of expensive
gems which brings the entire piece to an
impressive 2 million
no.not monopoly money actual dollars the
piece was actually donated to the
Smithsonian Museum back in 2003 so it's
not really available for sale or for
playing hands up if you're a huge
Monopoly fan Louie Vuitton teddy bear
almost every child has owned a teddy
bear at some point in their life and
some adults most likely still do they're
one of the most cuddly toys ever and for
some reason they even become a security
blanket and an important part of
childhood but what happens when that
teddy bear is worth more than the entire
home meet the stuffed animal that holds
a record for the most expensive teddy
bear toy it was designed by a German
toymaker and branded by the one and only
Louie Vuitton so you already know this
toy is going to be expensive AF so how
much does it cost this fashionista teddy
bear will cost you a sky-high 2.1
million dollars this teddy is made of
real fur and gold his eyes aren't your
regular eyes either they are made of
diamonds and sapphires yep you heard
that right now think about all your
teddy bears that have lost their eyes in
the process of growing up if that
happened to this one there wouldn't be
any harm done because you'd be an owner
of an actual diamond you can actually
see this fair and real life in the teddy
bear Museum in South Korea question is
would you want to own it
Szymanski's soccer ball kicking around
the soccer ball is something almost
every child has done at least once but
there's one soccer ball in this world
that can't be kicked well it can but
you'll probably end up in a lot of
trouble unless you own it it's the
shebanski soccer ball and it costs a
whopping two point five nine million
dollars yep it's more than a Louis
Vuitton teddy bear and way more than a
Monopoly made of gold this is a four
point eight pound soccer ball encrusted
with 3,500 carats of South African
diamonds we're talking about 6600
20 white diamonds and 2,640 black
diamonds yep that's why it looks so
awesome it was actually created to
commemorate the 2010 World Cup but
unlike the golden monopoly that took a
year to make this soccer ball took three
months but just imagine how frustrating
it must have been to put together all
those diamonds one by one crystal
replicas of the ball were also displayed
in local stores and then auctioned off
for charity you'd probably never be
allowed to kick a ball like this but can
we just take a moment to appreciate how
awesome it actually looks if we only had
2.5 million dollars to spare Lamborghini
toy car we're on to our top four most
expensive toys in the world and yep a
toy car cost more than a 2.5 million
dollar soccer ball which is pretty
impressive this isn't the type of car
you'd see a child play with and slam
into another car this is a toy replica
of a real Lamborghini and it actually
costs way more than the actual car a
real Lamborghini would cost you about
four hundred thousand dollars but this
toy costs 4.6 million dollars yep you
heard that right
and it's size is about 1/8 of the actual
Lamborghini it's pretty small but as
they say these things come in small
packages this luxurious toy is equipped
with gold diamonds and platinum rims in
its headlights steering wheel and seats
according to reports it took 500 hours
to complete this beauty it might not be
the same as five months or a year but
the sole dedication to this project
definitely paid off just think about it
this toy car basically costs about six
times more than the real Lamborghini
suddenly owning a real Lambo doesn't
seem that expensive does it Madame
Alexander Eloise of course the top three
most expensive toy in the world would be
a doll let's be honest
dolls are collectibles and because of
that people try to make them as
expensive as possible why because they
know people will buy them meet Madame
Alexander Eloise she was created by a
doll designer called Madame Alexander
who actually only made five dolls of
this type doll has 9 carats of diamonds
and several other expensive accessories
and it costs five million dollars Blue
Ivy's gold rocking horse can't even
compete in this
as this beautiful doll you can probably
see that the doll is also wearing real
fur she also has Swarovski's crystals
and Christian Dior clothes when you
count it off that does bring this doll
to an impressive five million dollars
all of these rare dolls come with the
chubby look blonde hair and a cute dog
the question is are you dog crazy enough
to ever even consider purchasing
something like this once again big
things come in small packages and small
dolls can apparently be worth five
million dollars the bird trainer say
what don't worry this has nothing to do
with actual real life herbs but it does
in fact have everything to do with dolls
this impressive doll is a lot bigger
than any toddler and it's actually kind
of alive and according to reports it's
actually a man it's a 4 foot tall moving
doll and it took more than 15,000 hours
to complete the unique doll has spring
driven cogs and gears that allow him to
move around he doesn't even need any
batteries to work with all you need to
do is wind up the golden key and the
bird trainer will play the flute you'll
also get to hear an actual tomb the doll
also comes with singing birds that will
flap their wings and turn their heads
which is pretty awesome
this definitely isn't your regular doll
you can just play with and throw around
so let's get down to business how much
does this thing cost the bird trainer
weighs an impressive 122 pounds and
costs six point two five million dollars
we're not even kidding and if that
didn't trust you you absolutely have to
check out our very last toy that's also
known as the most expensive toy in the
world
you're not ready for this one as dalat
dollhouse castle we told you there's
just something about dolls that makes
people want to design the most expensive
one ever but you're not ready for this
price this dollhouse is nothing like
you've ever seen before it comes with
multiple floors 29 rooms a gym a
swimming pool and even a basement and a
wine cellar it's like an actual
miniature mansion and we honestly wish
we could actually live in it just look
at how gorgeous it is it looks totally
real up close and even more impressive
from the inside every room is detailed
to perfection that will blow you
way the weights we have more statistics
for you this dollhouse
took 13 years to complete and it weighs
over 800 pounds whoa
it looks absolutely magical but you'll
never guess its price
are you ready it's eight point five
million dollars that's to weigh more
than a posh apartment in expensive
cities like New York and London how
crazy is that but don't worry the price
tag is actually used for good the owner
of the dollhouse donates the exhibition
proceeds to various kids charities the
real question is when can we move in and
that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]